all right the first cube that I ever
bought was this original 3x3 rubik's
cube invented by Erno Rubik and no cube
collection is really complete without a
3x3 original cube as you can tell the
cube is pretty beat-up I've had it for
about a year and a half and it doesn't
look this way because it's old but
because I sprayed it with a silicone
spray that has petroleum distillates in
it and anything that has petroleum
distillates will basically disintegrate
your internal plastic and also destroy
your stickers and make them look
something like this so if you want to
lubricate your cube use 100% silicone
try to stay away from the petroleum
distillates the first time I ever solve
this cube was March 1st of 2007 it was
not the first cube I ever solved the
first cube that I ever solved was a
keychain tube and I used to have a
keychain cube that I never mixed up and
one day my friend decided to mix it up
and that's when I decided that I wanted
to learn how to solve it and that's how
I got into CUBAN so the first time that
I broke one minute with this cube was
back in April 16th of O 7 so that's
about a month and a half from the day
that I bought it so give yourself about
a month to two months to get within a
minute and after I was able to solve it
within a minute I then went on to the
4x4 Rubik's cube solving the 4x4 was
pretty intuitive for me and I figured it
out within the first day I figured out
how to do these centers and the edges I
needed a little bit of help with the
parity but overall I was able to pretty
much do it most of it myself this cube
is pretty good it's uh it's a little bit
sticky if you turn it you take a look it
gets stuck a lot of times and these edge
pieces do pop out so the cube itself is
pretty good I'm sure they I think they
make them a little bit better now they
retooled the four by four and five by
five so I believe the first time that I
solved that I got eleven minutes I got
around eleven minutes and then I was
able to gradually get it down actually
the same day I did it for a while and I
got it down to four minutes and 41
seconds
so if you're just starting out and
you're solving it in 20 minutes give
yourself a little bit of time solve it
more and you'll eventually get it down
that first day probably within half the
time that you got it the first time you
solve it so overall this cube has been
pretty good the stickers I think held up
better than they did on this cube
because I didn't spray this one with the
petroleum distillates so after I was
able to solve this cube within around I
think three minutes I then went on to
the 5x5 rubik's cube professor and this
is the first professor that i ever
purchased as you can tell it's pretty
beat up as well some of the stickers on
some of the sides don't peel and then
some of the ones on the other sides do
so I have three sides that are peeling
and three sides that are pretty decent
which is kind of weird but anyway I had
to crazy glue these stickers back on and
I broke this piece here but this was not
one of my favorite 5x5 keeps to solve it
was actually really good at turning but
instead of buying a new piece from cube
Smith which I didn't know about back
then I just went on to buy a new cube
since I broke that piece so this is
basically the same exact model for of
the Rubik's professor it's not the exact
same one that they have out now which
they retooled and I'll show you what I
got from the rubik's company in a little
bit so after I was able to solve the 5x5
I believe the first time that I ever
solved that I got around 12 minutes and
then I was able to gradually get it down
within like a week or so I got it down
to around nine minutes and then within
two months I got it down to six and
around five and a half in about two and
a half months so give yourself some time
keep practicing and you'll eventually
drop the time down after I was able to
solve the 5x5 the 4x4 the 3x3 I had the
whole rubik's family I decided to give
the East Sheen cube to try so these are
basically cubes that are made in China
and they're pretty decent cubes actually
for speed selling they turn pretty well
and they're actually a lot cheaper than
the Rubik's brand now this cube is
really a lot smaller than this 5x5 as
you'll see this cube is actually close
to being the same size as the 3x3 so the
five by five East chin cube and the four
by four East chin cube are exactly the
same size and I got these both from
China and it took around three to four
weeks to get it I remember waiting for
it for a while so don't order from China
I actually this cube here is broken I
dropped it and the axis center piece it
cracked off and I actually crazy glued
it back on so it still print spins
pretty nicely but you can see that this
is this is actually broken here so I
don't really use this cube too much
anymore I decided to go on and buy
another set of another East Chien 5x5
cube and this time I bought it from
puzzle pros and this cube is is really
good I still use this cube a lot which
is why it's a more worn down than the
older one and I also bought a 3x3
do-it-yourself cube so when you get the
east gene cubes you'll actually get them
in these little boxes depending on which
model you get you could probably get it
with the plastic as well and it does
come with instructions on how to put it
back together because they are
do-it-yourself cubes so the
do-it-yourself 3x3 that I bought from
puzzle pros was a really good buy this
cube is is really good its quick it
spins nicely and once you lubricate it
with a little bit of silicone spray it
spins really nicely let me show you guys
so it's a really good cube and I'm glad
I bought it so after I bought that then
you know that I bought the the V cubes
the 6 and the 7 so if you haven't
already checked out the V Cube reviews
that I gave I gave an in-depth review of
the ups and downs of the V Cube 6 and 7
which you can find on my page alright so
after mr. Jones featured my videos on
the Academy section of the rubix comm
website they sent me this package as a
thank-you basically I have already
opened it and played around with some of
the stuff inside but it's in brand-new
condition and I packaged it just the way
it was when I first got it so the first
thing that I got was a Rubik's tote bag
which is really cool I would definitely
use this oh if I went to a competition
and wanted to bring some of my cubes and
other stuff like that
I also got a Rubik's championship
t-shirt it's the World Championship 2007
has all these cool logos and stuff so I
haven't actually gotten the chance to
wear this yet but I'm definitely going
to pretty soon I also got a Rubik's pen
which is brand new I haven't opened
anything yet and I got a Rubik's keikain
also and of course I got the keychain
cube which is the first cube that I ever
saw not this one of course but this is
the first kind of cube that I ever saw
this you can see it's teeny and it's
really not the first cube that you want
to be solving but it was fun and of
course they gave me a brand new retooled
5x5 rubik's cube professor now this is
totally different than the one I was
showing you before which is now in a big
pile over here it is a retool professor
so what that means is that they change
the
and use them on the inside and
everything like that these stickers are
also different you'll notice opposite
white is blue not yellow yellow is
actually over here opposite green so
that's the one thing that's different
it's also a lot smoother as you can see
I could I could turn these two layers
really gently and they'll spin really
fast so that's different so the cube
overall is a lot better than the older
rubik's cube this has become one of my
favorite speed cubes basically I solved
this 5x5 over the east gene now actually
and I get pretty decent times with and
as you could see the stickers are not
peeling at all on this cube so they're
different stickers as well alright guys
so that's basically my cube collection
and the new package that I got from
rubik's com
so as always you could check out the
review for the V cubes and I'm also
planning on doing a tutorial for the V
Cube 6 coming up soon so check that out
when I get it and also subscribe for a
notification of my videos alright guys
thanks for watching